What's up everybody?
Jared again?
Today we're talking about animation,
most powerful pipsqueak.
Sorry about that,
Edward.
Now full metal alchemist.
Brotherhood has all the trappings of an
instant classic high concept science
fiction Shit.
Awesome.
Fight scenes,
definitely strong philosophical core.
Well,
that's why we're here.
Wow.
Throughout Edward and Alphonse's journey
to restore their bodies.
The two are confronted with various
discourses on the efficacy and
application of science or in their case
alchemy.
Sure,
it's through alchemy that they hope to
recover their bodies,
but they also see it used for some
pretty awful things.
So what is brotherhood saying about
science and the way it's applied to this
world and how does faith fit into this
discussion?
Well,
let's find out.
Welcome to this wisecrack addition on
the philosophy of full metal alchemist,
brotherhood,
and of course spoilers ahead,
but first a quick primer full metal
alchemist.
Brotherhood is set in a mistress,
a country reminiscent of pre world war
two Europe who's defining feature is the
success of Alchemy or the manipulation
and altering of matter using natural
energy.
Alchemy is essentially treated as a
science one that combines chemistry and
biology with its own unique laws and
principles,
alchemies most important law,
the law of equivalent exchange,
non Nico,
you,
hello,
no
or you know the law.
That means if you get the right
materials and draw a circle,
you can do this.
The show establishes a push and pull
dynamic between science and faith almost
immediately in episode three hour travel
to the desert town of or to investigate.
Father coordinate below a holy figure
who has gained control of the people by
offering them with miracles and
indoctrinating them in the faith of Lido
wisdom.
The second they arrived,
though the brothers make their views
abundantly clear to the faithful
in general,
are you motivated
and their skepticism toward the divine
is justified.
As it turns out,
Cornell's miracles are just cleverly
bailed.
Applications of alchemy that he uses to
attract followers,
willing to die for him at an Alec
exposed.
Cornell is a fraud,
and liberate the people at your firm is
ideological tyranny.
So science rules,
faith drools,
right?
Well,
not so fast.
In the following episode,
the brothers are sent to study under the
sewing life alchemists show,
Tucker Tucker was the first outcome is
to successfully create a talking cmera
and tries to repeat his success in order
to retain his state alchemist
certification.
The rx fascination quickly turns to
horror and in one of the biggest gut
punches and anime history,
we see this.
Woo.
Yeah,
that's right.
Tucker actually used his family,
dog and his own daughter as components
to create his Camaro,
but far from feeling remorse.
Tucker claims he was only doing what
science demands
nondual Zinger,
you know,
simple moose,
little Jentezen Kendall,
Tau Mama Jemima.
Send that out
in the face of such an atrocity.
Science no longer seemed so innocent,
does it?
So where does this conflict between
science and faith lead us?
Tucker,
the amoral alchemist in search of
scientific knowledge at any cost largely
sets the tone for the rest of the show.
Over at 64 episodes,
Brotherhood forces us to question the
value of single mindedly clinging to
science and the consequences of reducing
all knowledge to scientific terms of
motive thought loosely known in the real
world.
As scientism,
now I know what you're thinking,
jared,
doubting science is what people in a
coat do,
but just humoring when philosophers
critique scientism,
they're not saying that science is a
lie.
What they're criticizing is how we put
scientific knowledge above all other
knowledge and how we try to reduce other
forms of knowledge into it.
According to philosopher Paul Fire,
Robin,
science is just one of many competing
explanatory frameworks,
one which is neither as rational nor
consistent as it pretends to be fire.
Robin's favorite example is copernicus,
who's heliocentric model of the universe
was actually rejected by scientists of
his day to them,
aristotle's idea of celestial spheres
offered a fuller explanation of why the
planets moved into the sky.
While Copernicus's model could correctly
calculate the movement of the planets.
It couldn't explain why they moved,
as they did until Newton's theory on
gravity was published over a century
later.
Science in this case wasn't interested
in the truth so much as self
preservation like any ideology fire.
Robin worries that an unquestioning
acceptance of it,
like with Leonora and Lito Ism can lead
to some potentially disastrous results
in his book against method in science
and a free society fire robin desks.
Is it not possible that science as we
know it today or a search for the truth
and the style of traditional philosophy,
will create a monster and monsters are
exactly what science creates in the
world of brotherhood,
such as manmade Camaro's that are
referred to as ungodly experiment
can put it into then when there is a
killer.
This impersonal dehumanizing aspect of
alchemy is enshrined in the law of
equivalent exchange,
which inherently reduces objects,
animals,
and even people to their physical
components.
The oreck brothers entire journey starts
because the to believe they can bring
their mother back to life by simply
transmuting the basic ingredients of a
human being.
This dehumanizing nature is furthered by
one of alchemies,
most sought after the philosopher's
stone.
When Ed and ell decode Dr Marquez notes,
they realize the key ingredient to the
stone is human life
kingdom.
The stone is the ultimate product of
alchemy allowing its users to ignore the
law of equivalent exchange,
but even though the stone can restore at
now's bodies,
the two are reluctant,
if not just plain unwilling to use the
stone.
In contrast,
the homonculus artificial humans powered
by philosopher stones regurgitate
scientific philosophy,
reducing the souls trapped within the
stones,
Tamir alchemic principles while Ed and
Al both use the power of the stones on
one occasion each they do so while
respecting the autonomy of those souls,
mother,
to stay me,
to cuddle.
You don't want me to come.
Committee,
this distinguishes the brothers as moral
according to philosopher Emmanuel Kant,
who famously stated that you must treat
humanity whether in your own person or
in the person of any other,
always at the same time as an end,
never merely as a means for people are
never meant to be used or reduced to
calculations,
but rather are always a goal in
themselves.
But an analysis problem with alchemy is
larger than it's impersonal nature,
but also it's subservience to the
military.
Alchemy is so under the control of the
industry and government that there are
actually three state appointed tenants
of Alchemy,
the first of which is the literally obey
the military who go drinking,
who knows,
somebody seeing him.
She didn't call me Jessica goodness.
In fact,
state alchemists are generally referred
to as dogs at the military and even as
human weapons.
Hey,
good.
In his book,
science wars sociologists,
Stanley Aronowitz,
argues that scientists often view
themselves as vehicles facilitating the
advancement of learning and by
application the progress of mankind.
Yet scientists funding must come from
somewhere and often it's from
corporations or the state.
As such,
scientists don't really own their
discoveries and have little say about
their application throughout the
animate.
Ed Constantly clashes with this
militarization of science by the state
and his own complicity with it.
As Alex Armstrong succinctly puts it,
couple
thinking just a shoe tie shoe and
they'll have a new Audi Shindand
accuser,
but the hospital loading it.
Recall it.
We even see this military influence
distort the basic principles of science.
When ed and ell reminisce about being
trained on a desert island as children,
they come to the epiphany that alchemy
is all about understanding the natural
flow of energy,
both deconstructing and reconstructing
it,
so now that Lcd Bouzouki stair cycle,
what this principle is leader,
twisted in the mouths of the military in
justifying destroying the whole country
and slaughtering its population.
One general even goes so far as to
rephrase it as alchemic rebirth.
Nice.
I see them almost that you didn't get a
coach,
you punk in night.
What do I do?
I didn't.
Social Security goes through to this
thing.
Lacey,
as tools of the government alchemists
have become the very instruments of the
series chief antagonist father who
controls the MSG in state,
father desires nothing more than to
assume the mantle of God,
a goal which he's used,
alchemy,
countless military conflicts and
millions of innocent lives to prepare
for.
In fact,
a masters is most brutal and heartless
war.
The war of extermination was fought just
a further father's plan and it's this
war where the state alchemists made
their largest military impact.
Good job or we've got an issue bothers
him.
It's all clinical.
What's shocking about each ball isn't
just the devastating force that alchemy
wrecked on it.
The scientific language used to explain
it.
Even the good guys here can't help but
couch.
What's essentially genocide in these
sterile scientific terms almost on the
cable issue.
Bird.
We can do that.
In fact,
this sanitizing nature of scientific
language is what escalated,
fallen wharton,
new heights as fear.
King Bradley told the high priest of the
shallow when he offered himself up in
exchange for a ceasefire.
The law of equivalent exchange won't
allow it
so much coaching or one on one or so
days,
the fewer even considered his wife to be
nothing more than an expendable pond for
his greater scheme.
Now,
if the title of purer is raising
eyebrows among you,
there's a good reason for that.
The country have a masters is
reminiscent of pre World War II,
Germany,
uh,
Milton nation expanding beyond its
borders and a blonde haired blue eyed
army whose uniforms look a lot like that
of the SSS.
Even the might is right motivation
behind Nazi Germany,
bubbles to the surface and a mistress as
general raven invoke social darwinism to
justify mass extermination.
So John,
when you could go so good though,
you know what you should see how you use
of.
That's not enough to convince you.
Then you only have to compare a
mistresses.
Human experiments did that of Auschwitz
as lead Dr Josef Mengele,
whether it's raising babies and
underground laboratories,
stitching together people in animals or
ripping soltes from bodies.
It's hard to say that a mistress lacks
the same wanton cruelty and morbid
scientific curiosity that defined mangle
his operations.
Mengele established a kindergarten at
Auschwitz for his younger experiments
allegedly stitching to gypsy girls
together,
and if he could have gotten his hands on
a literal soul,
he probably would have mutilated.
Oh yeah.
Did we mention that fire robin to
actually fought as a lieutenant in World
War II,
even earning an iron cross in the
process,
witnessing firsthand the scientific
arguments made by a dictatorship for war
and genocide.
It's no surprise that fire robin would
one day proposed a separation between
science and states with ultimate power
resting in democracy in his lecture,
how to defend society from science.
He argued there must be a formal
separation between state and science
just as there is now a formal separation
between state and church.
Scientists may be consulted on important
projects,
but the final judgment must be left to
the democratically elected consulting
bodies,
so it's safe to say that full metal
alchemist presents a cautionary tale
about the blind adherence to science,
but what does it say about faith?
Well,
throughout its 64 episode run,
faith is often portrayed as another
explanatory model,
another source of truth and power.
In fact,
for a show populated almost entirely by
scientists,
the characters make a number of appeals
to faith.
In the episode,
the miracle of Brush Valley and an owl
witness,
the delivery of a baby become awestruck
and point out the limitations of
alchemy.
Dr Marco,
the alchemist,
largely responsible for the creation of
the philosopher's stone during the civil
war,
calls it fate that he met the ish fallen
scar before the to set out together to
challenge the government.
Similarly,
Knox who worked as a doctor during the
war and was subsequently estranged from
his family invokes God when they've
returned to him.
Some of similar you can let me know.
Even Bradley,
a Homunculus wonders if his own death at
the hand of scar was providence coming
with Shinji.
No.
Good.
Cool.
You Know Kim?
Oh,
what in you are it
Bradley?
Who mercilessly killed these people
during the war was told that God would
strike him down one day and it was the
son looking like a crescent moon,
which together symbolize God in Alchemy
that blinded him and allowed scar too.
Right?
The finishing blow
is that the thematic takeaway of the
show?
Science is bad.
Faith is good.
So keep on praying.
Well,
not quite.
See the problem with scientism isn't
that science is bad and that non science
is good.
Fire.
Robin isn't giving the middle finger to
vaccines and posting about chem trails
on twitter.
Nope,
instead,
his main contention is that science is
just one of many ideas that propel
society and should be treated,
thus what fire alb into poses is any
unreflective,
veneration of any ideology because it
inhibits free thought as it turns out,
the blind following of science as the
arbiter of truth is just as harmful as
the blind following of faith as the
arbiter of truth,
whether it's father cornell and the
homonculus using the Lido is to incite
violence against their enemies or scar
using his god is Vala to justify his
vengeance against the alchemist
meaningfully Camino Sindhis.
Faith alone can be every bit justice,
scary as science characters grow and
brotherhood.
When they realized the limitations of
adhering to any one ideology,
Edward and Alphonse,
for example,
begin to question the foundations of
western Alchemy,
which supposedly takes us energy from
the tectonic movements of the earth's
mantle.
When father manages to cancel it out,
it's their quest for an explanation that
leads them to science as eastern
equivalent alcohol history,
which uses life energy from the planet.
It's ultimately bridging the gap between
these two ideologies that allows our
heroes to eventually trial.
The two different scientists come
together to make a reverse transmutation
circle that saves the lives of all
semesters.
Perhaps no character embodies this
development more than scar,
a survivor of the Ashmolean,
war of extinction,
scar target state alchemists out of
revenge to him not only are alchemists
weapons,
but they transgress against God who
alone possesses the right to create,
but as scar learns more about a
mistress,
he realizes how wrong he was to seek
vengeance.
No new tool you will can you committed
to you in show who who Costanoa Tj
scar who wants cloaked his actions and
the words of God finally understands
that no ideology can justify murder.
Scar even breaks from the strict laws
that govern his fate,
making use of the very alchemy that his
god a board in order to save the country
he wants hated
soldier code orange issue
bars.
Transformation stands in stark contrast
to the show's main antagonist.
Father,
who clings to his single minded belief
in science.
Father becomes obsessed with the power
of alchemy and takes this obsession to
the logical extreme.
Viewing mankind is little more than
materials for him to use in becoming God
was on blinded by scientism.
Father can't understand the value of
human emotions and discards them in his
attempt to become perfect.
He literally ripped the seven deadly
sins from himself.
Lust,
greed,
slaw,
gluttony,
envy,
wrath and pride.
Who in turn become the other homonculus.
Ultimately,
it's this conviction and the absolute
supremacy of science and the ability to
achieve perfection through it that
undoes father,
the souls trapped in the philosopher's
stone which he dismissed as we're
energy,
begin to assert their wills and rebel
against him.
Father,
conception of a soul as a mere
ingredient fails to account for the
autonomy of these individuals after an
epic punch to the gut,
father is finally killed and dragged
back into the void from whence he came
where he meets the real god of being
called truth.
Still desperately clinging to scientism.
Father demands to know what he did
wrong,
unlike scar and others.
Father refused to recognize any kind of
human wisdom beyond alchemy.
I didn't really three already.
All of this goes to show what makes ed
and now particularly special throughout
the series.
They're humble rejection of a single
ideology from the shows outset,
the to grapple with what alchemy is and
what it means to be a state alchemist.
The
this questioning that makes the
brother's seen both naive and likable at
the brothers core is a strong desire to
discover their own truth.
When psychopath extraordinary solve,
Jay Kim Lee has alphonse cornered.
He wonders why our hero doesn't just
take the philosopher's stone and get his
body back.
None of this will not.
Chicago,
Jibo,
Colorado Toady model stomach go online,
disco.
Sure,
the country would face certain
destruction from father,
but that's just equivalent exchange
inaction.
In order to get their bodies back,
they'd have to give up the world safety
tool.
Go quote on the Horse,
but our rejects that alchemic worldview
reaffirming their desire to find their
own truth.
Yes,
simple.
It's this search for possibilities that
distinguishes the brothers and allows ed
to make his final transmutation.
After al sacrifices himself in order to
give ed his arm back,
ed follows his brother into the portal
to bring him back.
When asked by the truth what price he'll
pay.
Edd smiles and offers this ability to
perform alchemy and recognizes the
arrogance and thinking that outcome.
He could explain everything,
let alone solve all his problems.
She didn't need to go to the citadel.
Coke.
It's the dog or the dog.
Unlike father who couldn't accept his
place in the universe and equated
alchemy with power.
Ed knows the truth.
No,
not anymore.
Keeps you the their bodies back in the
day.
Save what's left for our heroes to do in
typical elric fashion.
It's the keep searching for truth and
new methods to discover it.
As Alphonse puts it,
they want to give back to the people who
helped them all along their journey,
but it's not a simple given.
Take not a cold formula like the law of
equivalent exchange.
Yeah.
June,
July.
She's like it.
A book that see
did that end.
Alice traveling east and Ed West in
hopes of gathering all the knowledge to
make this principle a reality.
Of course,
old habits tend to die hard and when ed
finally confesses his feelings too,
when it comes out like this.
Humble.
Yeah,
of course.
Maybe ed didn't need to go so far from
home to realize that science alone can't
explain everything.
We waited 64 episodes for that moment
and it was damn worth it.
So what do you think wise,
crack?
Well,
pure devotion to science lead us down a
dark path.
Do we need to inject a little?
I Dunno,
maybe philosophy into how we look at the
world.
Let us know what you think in the
comments.
As always,
thanks for watching.
Peace.
Hey,
thanks for watching.
Wise crack.
Although father may have been condemned
for seeking perfection,
there's nothing wrong with looking for
the perfect streaming service and if
you're on that quest,
you're gonna want to check out?
That's VRV.
It's made by our friends over at crunchy
roll and they want to give wisecrack
fans seven days of free.
Sweet hd ad free viewing verb is a mega
service,
which means you get your fill of full
metal alchemist on crunchy roll.
Then you can hop over to funimation to
catch up on attack on Titan,
then dropped by CSO for some harmonquest
all on the same site.
They even got some exclusive episodes of
bravest warriors,
another show from the creator of
adventure time.
It's much weirder and much darker and we
think you're going to love it.
Head over to [inaudible] dot co slash
wise crack or click the link in the
description for your free seven day
verve combo pack.
You can get it on your desktop,
on their mobile APP,
Roku,
playstation,
and xbox.
Thanks to [inaudible] for sponsoring
this video and we've got tons more great
stuff on the way,
including videos on finding dory
spirited away and guardians of the
galaxy volume two,
so I'll be sure to head over to our
channel page,
hit that subscribe button and ring that
bell.
Thanks again for watching and for all
your support.
We couldn't do it without you guys.
Seriously,
thanks a lot everybody.
Piece.